[Musique]
PL c'est possible et notre invité
politique ce matin c'est Sandrine
Rousseau bonjour merci d'être avec nous
député écologiste de Paris on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par Fabrice
vessedon du groupe ébrra les journaux de
l'Est de la France bonjour Fabrice
bonjour Orian bonjour Sandrine rousse
bonjour on va commencer Sandrine
Rousseau en parlant de la crise agricole
et et vendredi jeudi Gabriel hatal a
fait une série d'annonces est-ce que le
premier ministre a réussi à bien gérer
cette crise agricole mais il a cogéré
avec la FNSEA et les agriculteurs sont
sortis dans la rue avec leur tracteurs
pour réclamer des revenus à la fin ils
ont moins de normes environnementales
mais toujours pas de revenu en fait donc
là il y a eu aussi des mesures concern
non mais il il y a vraiment rien de
structurel qui permet de changer la
donne sur le plan du revenu et il y a
surtout rien qui permet d'anticiper les
effets it que va que va avoir le
réchauffement climatique sur l'activité
agricole et en fait je pense qu'il y a
une inquiétude légitime et importante
dans le monde agricole de ces changement
qui enfin les agriculteurs ont
l'habitude de dire qu'ils gardent un an
de récolte enfin un an d'argent d'avance
pour essayer de gérer les mauvaise
récolte là on voit que les années de
sécheresse par exemple se cumulent les
unes aux autres et qu'en fait les
rendements agricoles dans certaines
régions de France commencent à diminuer
sérieusement donc il y a quelque chose
de structurel à aller chercher on n'est
pas du tout là-dedans et je rappelle
quand même que la FNSEA à à une espèce
de main mise sur le monde agricole dont
il faudrait questionner la pertinence et
la légitimité parce que le mode de
scrutin dans les chambres d'agriculture
leur donne une espèce de pouvoir bien
bien exagéré par rapport à ce qu'il à ce
qu'il représente lé F pour vous bah en
tous les cas ils ont un mode de de ils
ont un mode de désignation dans les
chambres d'agriculture qui font que qui
fait que ils mettent ils ont la main
mise sur le monde agricole et là on le
voit ils ont négocié essentiellement
pour les plus gros je pense que ARN le
directeur de la FNSEA est très satisfait
des des mesures qui sont prises je ne
suis pas certaine que les petits
agriculteurs qui peineent qui sont à la
peine qui n'ont pas d'emploi ou très peu
d'emploi sur leur ferme et qui sont avec
des des des horaires de 70 ou 80 heur
par semaine soit très satisfait de ce
qui sort mais sur les revenus il y a
quand même une pression qui est mise sur
les distributeurs pour revoir la loi
égalim il y a 150 millions qui ont été
annoncés de soutien fiscal pour vous
c'est c'est rien non non sur la loi
alors sur la loi égalim je rappelle
quand même que la grande distribution à
ses centrales d'achat a mis ses
centrales d'achat à l'extérieur de la
France Leclerc est à Bruxelles Carrefour
est à Madrid et SuperU est en Hollande
pour bénéficier du droit hollandais du
droit espagnol et du droit belge que d'ù
la volonté d'un égalisme Européen et le
discours de Gabriel Attal et d'Emmanuel
Macron qui disent il faut respecter la
loi française même quand on négocie de
la France faut s'en prendre à ces à ces
grandes distributions à cette grande
distribution y compris par une taxe sur
les surprofits qui ils ont fait pendant
l'inflation puisque je rappelle que
leurs profits ont explosé pendant
l'inflation donc ils sont des profiteurs
de crise et puis derrière il faut des
prix planchers et il faut revoir le
système agricole pour que chaque
agriculteur soit respecté dans son
travail dans sa dignité d'agriculteur là
on n'est pas du tout là-dedans
c'est-à-dire que par exemple je prends
un exemple ils ont annoncé des contrôles
par la DGCCRF 10000 contrôle par la DGCC
répression des frudes par la répression
des fr les grandes surfaces euh sur dans
grandes surface les les inspecteurs de
la DGCCRF donc de la répression des
fraudes ont
été diminué il y a un/art de ces
inspecteurs qui ont disparu en en un peu
plus de 10 ans donc en fait tout cela
n'est que de encore une fois un
ministère de la parole et mais je pense
que là ça commence à se voir qu'il n'y a
aucune espèce de capacité ni à négocier
ni à monter un rapport de force et qu'à
la fin on tape sur ce qu'il y a de plus
facile c'est-à-dire les normes
environnementales mais je rappelle que
les normes environnementales ne sont pas
là pour embêter qui que ce soit ils sont
là pour protéger notre santé
justement vous nous dites que l'écologie
est perdante dans cette négociation elle
n'est pas perdante elle est piétinée
elle est piétinée est-ce que aujourd'hui
à l'heure où le réchauffement climatique
s'emballe et où il devient hors de
contrôle est-ce qu'il est vraiment
pertinent d'aller piétiner les normes
environnementales enfin vraiment est-ce
la priorité du monde agricole les
chercheurs parlent de maladaptation
quand on fait ça c'est-à-dire que on ne
trouve pas les bonnes réformes dans un
problème qui est structurel et
systémique donc non là l'écologie est
piétinée est-ce que c'est vraiment
responsable de la part d'un chef de
l'État et d'un Premier ministre que
d'accréditer le fait que le problème
c'est l'écologie honnêtement je pense
qu'on est pas du tout rendeb de c'est
pas ce qu'ils disent hein personne enfin
en tout cas gabrielal n'a jamais dit le
problème c'est l'écologie si il parle
d'écologie punitive en permanence et
l'écologie n'est ramené qu'à quelque
chose de punitif je rappelle quand même
que dans le plan écofyo il y avait cette
volonté de diminuer les pesticides qui
n'est pas remise en cause mais bien sûr
que si c'est c'est en pause bien sûr que
si il y a des clusters de cancer
d'enfant dont on soupçonne que les
causes soient lié aux pesticides je
rappelle qu'en charante maritime il y a
des parents qui se battent par exemple
pour que leur le cancer de leurs enfants
soit reconnu comme étant lié au
pesticides en c'est ça qu'on est en
train de de casser avec le plan avec la
pose du plan un problème en France et
pas seulement qu'en France c'est qu'on
demande aux agriculteurs de faire
autrement mais ils n'ont pas franchement
d'alternative quant au produits à
utiliser non mais c'est la question
c'est pas une alternative quant au
produits à utiliser sans changer le le
mode la manière de faire agricole c'est
ça le sujet c'est que si vous continuez
à vouloir faire du maïs de manière
intensive pour aller les vendre à des
centrales d'achat qui vont les revendre
sur des marchés financiers pour une
spéculation mondiale et être en
concurrence avec le maïs du monde entier
si vous voulez faire ça alors évidemment
vous avez besoin de produits
phytosanitaire mais précisément la
question c'est comment assure-t-on la
souveraineté alimentaire de la France et
non pas une agriculture exportatrice qui
est en concurrence avec les pires
pratiques agricoles mondiales et en fait
mais l'année dernière Sandrine Rousseau
on a on a on a moins on a moins produit
de maïs on a produit plus de tournesol
c'est bien la preuve que les
agriculteurs changent mais les
exportations agricoles si vous regardez
les exportations agricoles ça reste
majoritairement des grands céréaliers
qui sont en concurrence encore une fois
avec des pays qui n'ont pas la même
législation écologique est-ce qu'il faut
s'aligner sur le bas la réponse est NON
et puis par ailleurs je je je le pose
ici parce que je n'ai pas beaucoup
entendu mais il va falloir aussi qu'on
s'intéresse à la manière dont nous
consommons puisque aujourd'hui le la
part des produits transformés dans notre
alimentation a progressé c'est-à-dire
qu'on prend des plats tout fait des
petits fours déjà fait et cetera tout
cela met en danger le monde agricole
puisque à chaque fois que vous utilisez
un produit transformé ce produit
transformé peut avoir 10 50 ou 100
ingrédients dont on ne sait pas d'où ils
viennent et à quel prix ils ont été
acheter et en fait ça ça renvoie
derrière à un modèle de société c'est
est-ce qu'on a le temps de cuisiner
est-ce qu'on a le temps de manger est-ce
qu'on a le temps de de consommer des
produits qui sont non transformés et
donc qu'il faut travailler et en fait ça
renvoie derrière à aussi une
organisation du travail à une
organisation des logements et c'est pour
cela que la crise agricole elle renvoie
à quelle société nous voulons et est-ce
que nous voulons une société du respect
des agriculteurs de la terre et de
nous-même ou est-ce que nous voulons une
société qui
s'intensifie en capitalistiquement qui
va sur les marchés financiers et qui
détruit à peu près tout ce qu'elle
touche on va revenir sur plusieurs
points que vous avez abordé d'abord le
le plan écofito Christophe Béchu le
ministre de la transition écologique
précise hier que c'est une pause de 3
semaines le temps de revoir les
indicateurs et que l'objectif de baisse
des pesticides de 50 % d'ici à 2030
n'est pas abandonné on est quand même
loin d'un recul de l'écologie bah déjà
je suis contente d'entendre Christophe
Béchu parce que pour l'instant je ne
na'avait pas entendu donc je suis
heureuse de l'entendre sur quelque chose
qui le concerne au premier rang la
deuxième chose c'est queà chaque fois
qu'on met quelque chose en pause on
admet qu'il y a un problème derrière
donc on aurait pu là il y a un problème
d'indicateur pour vous il y a pas de
problème d'indicateur non mais là le
plan écofyo bon il n'a jamais réussi à
être appliqué je rappelle que à chaque
fois qu'il y a eu une tension sur le
glyphosate sur les néonicotinoïdes on
est revenu en arrière c'estàdire qu'il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui eu de signal
envoyé fort au monde agricole qu'il
fallait diminuer ces produits
phytosanitaires mais juste il faut pas
il faut pas revoir l'indicateur il faut
pas un indicateur européen qui soit le
même pour tous qui soit le même pour
tous les les pays Europ pas si on a
besoin d'une harmonisation au niveau
européen mais on n' pas besoin de mettre
en pause un plan qui vise à diminuer la
part des phytosanitaires dans l' en in
trant dans l'agriculture je rappelle que
non
mais quel est le message qui est envoyé
quel est le message qui est envoyé c'est
que le problème c'est le plan écophyo on
a plus d'oiseaux on a plus de verre de
terre on a une biodiversité des sols qui
est en train de s'effondrer est-ce
aujourd'hui les indicateurs est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui les indicateurs français
étaient les bons Sandrine Rous est-ce
qu'il ne tenaient pas trop compte de la
quantité de produit plutôt que de la
qualité de la toxicité de ces produits
les deux il faut à la fois la quantité
il faut tenir compte de la quantité on
ne peut pas avoir une réduction des des
produits phytosanitaires si on s'attaque
pas à la
quantité et à la toxicité aussi je
rappelle que par ailleurs il y a aussi à
revoir la toxicité sur tout le cycle de
vie de ces produit puisque par exemple
un produit comme le glyphosate lorsqu'il
se décompose dans le sol ces
sous-produits sont tout aussi dangereux
que le produit initial donc il y a avoir
l'intégralité de la toxicité sur le
cycle de donc est-ce qu'il ne faut pas
mieux une pause de 3 semaines pour avoir
des indicateurs plus efficace et un plan
écopyo plus efficace plutôt que de dire
à tout prix il faut pas de pause moi je
vous dis il faut revoir pour que ce soit
plus efficace mais plus efficace dans la
diminution je n'ai rien entendu
aujourd'hui du gouvernement qui assure
qu'il y aura une diminution des produits
écofito l'objectif je l'ai pas entendu
non je ne l'ai pas entendu il dit juste
on va revoir ça il ne dit pas on va
diminuer la part des produits
phytosanitaires dans l'agriculture il ne
dit pas ça c'est ça qui manque comme
phrase aujourd'hui dans le dans dans la
parole gouvernementale sur la question
des exportations puisque vous en avez
parlé ça veut dire que pour vous il faut
arrêter les exportations qu'est-ce qu'on
fait je pense que la priorité doit être
à la souveraineté de la France à la
souveraineté alimentaire de la France et
à la souveraineté alimentaire de
l'Europe mais d'abord à la souveraineté
alimentaire de la France et aujourd'hui
il y a une espèce d'ambiguité entre ces
mots souveraineté qui sont posés de
manière régulière mais derrière les
mesures qui sont prises visent à
favoriser les exportations et à rendre
compétitif les agriculteurs sur les
marchés internationaux est-ce qu'on a
besoin que les agriculteurs français
soient compétitifs sur les marchés
internationaux à ça je réponds en tant
qu'écologiste non non malgré les
milliards que les exportations
rapportent à l'agriculture française de
pay non mais là on a besoin d'une
agriculture résiliente résistante vous
enfin on ne se rend pas compte de
l'ampleur du changement qui qui est à
l'œuvre là il estit enfin je je dis ça
pour qu'on se rende bien compte par
exemple à Paris moi qui suis sur Paris
les températures minimales auxquell nous
allons être confrontés sont les
températures de Séville vous imaginez
bien que le sud de la France va avoir
une agriculture une viticulture
profondément modifiée profondément
modifiée est-ce que la priorité
aujourd'hui c'est d'aller exporter sur
les marchés internationaux ou d'adapter
les méthodes agric fait parceon on a une
balance commerciale qui est très
déficitaire ce qui marche par exemple
c'est l'exportation de vin et spiritueux
là c'est excédentaire on arrête ça et
ben par exemple les vin spiritiritueux
sont parmi les plus en danger dans le
système agricole actuel les plus en
danger moi j'étais allé pendant la
primaire des écologistes donc il y a 2
ans maintenant voir les viticulteurs
d'occcitanie j'étais allé à un salon des
viticulteurs discutai avec eux ils
étaient dans une inquiétude quant à la
sécheresse du sol quant à leur capacité
à poursuivre leur activité il y a 2 ans
qui étaient énorme comment ça se fait
qu'on découvre la la crise de la
viticulture aujourd'hui comment se
fait-il que entre il y a 2 ans et
aujourd'hui il n'y ait pas eu de mesures
structurelles excusez-moi une petite
précision vous parlez beaucoup de
souveraineté française nationale ou
parler pas de souveraineté européenne si
je vous dis si si je vous dis d'abord la
souveraineté de la France ensuite la
souveraineté de l'Europe mais on va pas
aller chercher on va pas aller se mettre
en concurrence avec les céréaliers ou
avec l'élevage argentin ou néozélandais
ou je ne sais quoi selon vous c'est
possible de réformer dans système de
production agricole actuel dans l'Europe
actuelle alors ça c'est un des sujets et
non dans l'Europe actuelle cela n'est
pas possible et il faut revoir les
modalités de fonctionnement
intraeuropéens pour faire en sorte que
nous ne soyons pas dans un système
productiviste agricole qui est largement
encouragé et développé aujourd'hui par
la politique agricole commune mais c'est
un énorme sujet et il faut revoir les
traités de libre échange pour que les
produits agricoles n'en fassent pas
partie du coup est-ce que vous voterez
l'inscription de la souveraineté
alimentaire dans la loi comme le
souhaite Gabriel hatthal on verra ce
qu'il y a d'autres parce que des mots
nous nous sommes habitués au mots de
Gabriel hatal
Fabrice on va passer dans un autre sujet
on va passer à la votation qui avait
lieu hier à Paris sur la question des
mais j'imagine qu'en tant que député de
Paris vous avez suivi et vous avez voté
d'ailleurs tout à fait je suis allé
voter alors vous avez voté quoi j'ai
voté pour la l'augmentation de du
tarifnement bon alors deux questions
l'une sur le fond est-ce que c'est un
procès à la voiture en
ville est-ce qu'on ne veut plus du tout
de voiture à Paris déjà sur ce pointl et
puis sur la forme comment vous expliquez
que les Parisiens se déplacent quasiment
pas 5 % de participation c'est
finalement très peu sur un sujet aussi
essentiel oui alors pour les trtinet
hein qui dont on avait dit que c'était
un succès je crois qu'il y avait 7 % de
participation donc c'était pas beaucoup
plus ça ça interroge ces formes de
démocratie directe qui sont très
réclamés par les citoyens et citoyennes
c'estàdire que à chaque élection il y a
une demande de de plus grande
participation des citoyens au processus
démocratique là ça
fa manifestement ils n'y vont pas
massivement en tous les cas ça voilà ça
fait partie des questions que l'on doit
se poser c'estàd si on doit aller vers
une démocratie d'avantage direct ce que
je j'appelle de mes vœux ce que
j'appelle de mes vœux parce que je pense
que on a un problème en France qui est
que on a une élection puis après 5 ans
après on en a une autre et entre les
deux finalement les citoyens se sentent
très dépossédés du de l'exercice
démocratique donc je pense que la
démocratie directe est un sujet
nécessaire mais là manifestement ça ne
mobilise pas les foules après je vais
vous dire moi-même j'ai j'ai j'ai eu
j'ai mis du temps à comprendre que
c'était S weekend et donc je pense que
il y avait des affiches bah il y avait
des affiches dans Paris mais même même
moi elle ne m'avait pas interpellé alors
que pourtant je suis quand même parmi
les cibles principales donc voilà je
pense qu'il y avait quelque chose
peut-être à revoir sur le plan de
l'organisation mais et après il faut
peut-être aussi interroger les Parisiens
et parisiennes pour leur demander si
finalement ce type de consultation les
agrée ou pas si il faut une consultation
sur le type de consultation pas une
consultation mais est les interrogés
pour savoir pourquoi ils ne sont pas V
sur le fond oui ben sur le fond ce
procès à la
voiture on veut plus de voiture en ville
alors là c'est pas n'importe quel
voiture c'est des voitures qui font plus
de 1,6 tonnes oui ah non mais c'est pas
n'importe quel non c'est pas n'importe
quelle voiture et parce que j'ai entendu
tout ce weekend j'ai entendu que c'était
les voitures familiales des banlieux qui
arrivaient dans Paris non j'ai regardé
par exemple un Picasso qui est la
voiture familiale par excellence fait
fait moins d'1,6 tonnes donc en fait
c'est vraiment un monpace ça fait plus
d'un,6 B ça dépend le le Picasso par
exemple c'est 1,6on donc c'est moins
donc c'est c'est vraiment les très
grosses voitures qui sont des signes
extérieurs de richesse des signes
ostentatoires de richesse et qui sont
des signes ostentatoires de richesse
polluante pe l des class une petite
lutte des class exctement exactement
qu'il y ait un petit principe de
pollueur payeur sur les très grosses
voitures qui sont des objets très
ostentatoires franchement je ne trouve
pas ça mal et au contraire même et qu'en
plus sur les voitures électriques qui
pèsent très lourd mais les des voitures
électriques on a le même problème
qu'avec les voitures thermiques c'est si
vous faites des voitures électrique de
plus de 2 tonnes ça n'a strictement
aucun intérêt écologique en réalité
aucun donc ça ça fait partie de des
adaptations aussi que nous devons avoir
de notre mobilité c'est que nous devons
diminuer le poids des voitures pour
revenir à des poids de voitures qui
permettent des consommation sauf que
juste pardon C cette consultation ça ça
concernait pas le le tarif résidentiel
des Parisiens c'est-à-dire le
Paris il pe ài est-ce que c'est un
problème est-ce qu'il aurait fallu aller
plus loin et que ça concerne tout le
monde compris les Parisiens à titre
personnel je pense que nous aurions pu
aller beaucoup plus loin mais à titre
personnel je pense aussi que nous
devrions nous nous intéresser au
constructeurs de voitures et faire en
sorte que ces voitures là soient doté
d'un malus bien plus importantce un peu
est-ce que c'était un peu électoraliste
de la part d'analgo qui a pas voulu
froisser ses
électeurs pourquoi ce serait
électoraliste parce que quand question
les Parisiens sur une mesure quic qui
finalement ne les concerne pas est-ce
que il y a pas eu un peu la peur de ne
pas aller jusqu'au bout concême si si ça
les concerne quand même parce que quand
vous quand vous le garez au pied de chez
vous vous n'êtes pas concerné mais quand
vous vous déplacez dans Paris vous êtes
concerné donc si ça les concerne aurait
pas fallu aller plus loin et y compris
taxè le stationnement Résid je suis pour
aller plus loin je suis pour aller plus
loin sur ces grosses voitures je
rappelle que ces SUV sont responsables
d'une pollution ils consomment 20 % de
plus ils émettent des particules fines
qui nous rendent malad qui ont qui
génère des maladies à la fois pulmonaire
cancer et cardio-ovasculaire ça n'est
pas possible voilà je le dis très
clairement moi je veux que nous allions
beaucoup plus loin je salue quand même
ce premier pas saluonsle on voit bien
que dès qu'il y a une norme
environnementale les quatre freins sont
sont activés sur an dalalgo est-ce que
vous souhaitez qu'elle se représente à
nouveau en 2026 je souhaite rien du tout
moi je je je elle est libre de cette
décision et nous ferons en fonction de
sa décision est-ce ça veut dire est-ce
que vous si elle se représente pas vous
réfléchissez à une candidature en 26 ah
mais Mo je enfin là on est en 2024 donc
c'est dans 2 ans Mo les trucs de de an
quand on va être maère de Paris c'est
pas non plus très très loin non mais on
verra on verra là il y a des processus à
l'intérieur de chaque parti on verra à
l'intérieur de mon parti comment ça va
se dérouler il va y avoir je pense
plusieurs candidatures on verra ah vous
AZ envz env mais non je aujourd'hui je
je ne vous dirai rien là-dessus parce
que je n'en sais strictement rien on
verra ce que le parti des écologistes
mais vous l'excz pas est-ce que vous
voterez pour la réforme du mode de
scrutin Paris lon Marseille pour que le
maire soit élu de manière directe et non
pas via les maires d'arrondissement mais
ça ça fait partie des les scrutins
indirects sont très peu compris d'une
manière générale puisque que ce soit les
communautés d'agloot les communautés
urbaines ou les ou les mares de grandes
villes comme Paris lyonmseille ce ce
mode de suffrage indirect ne représente
pas la le poids de qu' l'on peut avoir à
l'intérieur d'un territoire puisque je
rappelle que c'est chaque arrondissement
qui vote après pour le maire moi je suis
la démocratie la plus simple et la plus
directe la plus visible possible donc
oui là-dessus il y a pas de problème un
mot sur les Européennes et votre
candidate Marie toussin qui ne décolle
pas dans les sondages est-ce que le
choix de votre tête de list n'était pas
le bon alors je vais vous dire si le
succès de l'écologie dépendit d'une tête
de list vu le nombre de têtes de lis que
nous avons essayé partout en Europe nous
ça se saurait donc non je ne pense pas
que la responsabilité soit à Mar et tout
ça je pense qu'il y a un une une
difficulté à imposer l'écologie dans le
débat politique et c'est
pourquoi parce que les européennes ça
vous réussit pas mal généralement
pourquoi là ça a l'air de pas marcher
c'était un peu votre élection quand même
ah bah c'est pas passé hein ça vous aura
pas échappé que le scrutin est devant
nous et que parfois il y a des surprises
et que là je suis sûr qu'il y en aura
une j'appelle vraiment tous les
électeurs électrices qui sont un peu
sensibles aux questions écologique à
aller voter parce que on le voit dans la
crise agricole s'il n'y a pas
d'écologiste il n'y a pas d'écologie à
la fin il n'y a pas de protection ni de
notre santé ni de la planète donc
levez-vous vraiment mobilisez-vous nous
avons besoin de VOUS hier dans le
parisien je sais pas si vous avez lu cet
article pierre Jouvet qui est le
porte-parole du PS disait Marie toussin
n'est pas la plus radicale mais elle est
chargée d'un imaginaire dans l'esprit
des gens en zone rurales les écolos
c'est tout de suite Sandrine Rousseau
est-ce que vous êtes un repoussoir à
voter écolo ah bah écoutez venez avec
moi dans les zones venez avec moi dans
les zones rurales et vous verrez que
c'est pas du tout le cas et par ailleurs
je trouve que ça c'est non mais ça c'est
l'argument facile qui est envoyé en
disant on a un problème mais je moi j'ai
entendu on a un problème con Bendit j'ai
entendu on a un problème Noël ma mère à
une époque j'ai entendu on a maintenant
j'entends on a problème sansau je pense
que ceux qui disent ça ont un problème
avec l'écologie c'est une hypothèse que
je pose PS un problème avec l'écologie
pour vous le PS a un problème avec
l'écologie ah ben je pense que il ferait
bien de regarder avec attention les
votes qu'ils font partout de de la
commune à l'Europe et que il y aurait un
sujet à regarder de près oui en effet
l'ensemble des votes c'est quand même
une réussite pour vous d'être le
problème c'est une réussite d'être le
problème je le poserai pas comme ça mais
surtout je vois pas en quoi je suis un
problème parce que je reprends votre
expression à l'instant hein sûr il y
avait un problème ma mère un problème
conbendit il y a un problème Rousseau
c'est que vous avez réussi occuper un
espace à vous inster quelque part
manifestement j'incarne une une écologie
et je vous dis c'est une écologie
radicale féministe antiraciste et que
oui je suis fière de la portere est-ce
est-ce qu'en cas d'échec aux européennes
il faudra poser la question de maintien
de marine Tondelier à la tête des
écologistes au moment des après les
européennes au moment des conr dans les
con si les européennes sont un échec et
que Marine Tondelier doit quitter la
tête des écologies dans les congrès on
interroge toujours les stratégies
politiques qui sont menées nous
l'interrogerons évidemment à ce
moment-là mais permettez que N nous
menons une que nous menions bataille
après bataille sur la une question qui
concerne le Parlement la question de
l'IVG l'Assemblée nationale a voté
largement pour une
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG en
votant pour la liberté garantie
formulation qui semble penser problème
au Sénat est-ce que vous pensez qu'une
version commune sera
trouvée je l'espère et et je dis à
Gérard Larcher ne ratez pas cette marche
de l'histoire ne ratez pas cette marche
de l'histoire j'entends bien que en tant
que président du Sénat vous ayez un avis
très tranché sur ce que l'on doit faire
du corps des femmes mais là en
l'occurrence c'est une c'est une étape
historique il est pas contre l'IVG il
est
contre par oui enfin c'est toujours
pareil c'est qu'à la fin on se demande
quand même contre quoi il est et là en
l'occurrence ce serait un une étape
historique qui montrerait que c'est un
droit fondamental c'est une liberté
fondamental accorder aux femmes et je
dis à Gérard Larcher vous avez
rendez-vous avec l'histoire c'est votre
famille politique qui a fait passer
l'IVG dans la loi française ne soyez pas
à la tête d'une fronde contre son
inscription à l'intérieur de la
Constitution nous avons ce droit nous
devons le garantir et nous devons
montrer l'exemple à l'ensemble des pays
du monde est-ce que si le Sénat revient
à sa première version c'est-à-dire
liberté et non plus liberté garantie ce
serait acceptable pour vous non c'est
une liberté garantie des déjà la
formulation telle qu'elle est fait
référence à la loi renvoie dans la
Constitution à la loi et c'est en soi
une forme d'affaiblissement donc on ne
peut pas aller en deessin une dernière
question Fabrice oui pour parler de cet
hommage qui sera rendu mercredi aux
victimes du Hamas vous irez vous y
participerez oui je je vais y aller
parce que je rends hommage aux victimes
je je signale jusque là aujourd'hui il y
a une situation à Gaza qui est une
situation d'une extrême gravité je
lisais en arrivant qu'il y a 19000
enfants qui sont aujourd'hui seuls à
Gaza parce que soit leurs parents sont
mort soit déplacés soit sans soin je
dire là on a une situation humanitaire
d'une gravité extrême moi je voudrais
que nous posions la question à Israël
quel est votre but quel est votre but
aujourd'h posez la même question
qu'ericel hier Arafa finalement pardon
vous posez la même question que votre
collègue ericokel hier Arafa oui moi moi
si j'étais allé à Arafa je serais aussi
allée à Jérusalem pour poser la même
question que je pense que là nous ne
devons pas être dans quelque chose qui
monte les uns contre les autres mais qui
permet les conditions de la paix et pour
permettre les conditions de la paix il
faut discuter avec les deux partis là en
l'occurrence la situation à Gaza devient
gravissime et je pense que nous devrions
élever la voix pour demander à ce que
les combats s'arrêtent elle est fit à sa
place à l'hommage mercredi matin mais
s'il le souhaite venir et rendre hommage
je pense malgré leur déclaration sur
laamass qui ont fait polémique non mais
je après on peut on peut leur dire que
leurs positions ne sont pas acceptables
mais s'ils veulent rendre hommage je
trouverai dommage qu'on leur interdisent
l'hommage parce que c'est un hommage qui
est finalement est national et en
soutient aux proches des personnes qui
ont été soit tué soit pris en otage
merci Sandrine Rousseau merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité merci Fabrice
on passe au club des territoires